and raise your right hand I will begin
by swearing you in in the public glare
the people the players and the process
that will decide the president's fate
with one key question did he abuse his
office for political gain the matter is
as simple and as terrible as that our
answer to these questions will affect
not only the future of this presidency
but the future of the presidency itself
and what kind of conduct or misconduct
the American people may come to expect
from their commander-in-chief this
spectacle is doing great damage to our
country it's nothing more than an
impeachment process in search of a crime
bill Taylor the top US diplomat in
Ukraine delivered an early bombshell
linking the president directly with a
quid pro quo and revealing a previously
unknown phone call between mr. Trump and
the EU ambassador
Gordon Sunland following the call with
President Trump the member of my staff
asked ambassador Sungmin what president
Trump thought about Ukraine Wester song
and responded that President Trump cares
more about the investigations of Biden
which Giuliani was pressing for Taylor
was damning about withholding aid and
says he raised the alarm to withhold
that assistance for no good reason other
than help with the political campaign
made no sense it was it was
counterproductive to all of what we had
been trying to do it was illogical it
could not be explained it was crazy but
Republicans had that chief attack dog
primed with a rapid round of biting
questions Besser you weren't on the call
were you the president you didn't listen
in on president Trump's call and
president lessees call either Dodd
you've never talked with chief of staff
Mulvaney I never did you never met the
president that's correct
yeah three meetings again with szalinski
and it didn't come up and two of those
they had never heard about as far as I
know president there's no reason for
presidents liske never made an
announcement this is this is what I
can't believe and you're their star
witness but George Kent
the other half of the professorial
pairing testifying also expressed deep
concern about the president's lawyer
conducting his own foreign policy in
mid-august it became clear to me that
Giuliani's efforts to gin up politically
motivated investigations were now
infecting u.s. engagement with Ukraine
so what of the man of the moment well he
says he was too busy to watch I hear
it's a joke I haven't watched I haven't
watched for one minute because I've been
with the president which is much more
important as far as I'm concerned the
president and Republicans are depicting
this as a partisan sham and the country
appears to be as divided as Washington
many people simply don't believe what
they see on their TV screens and they
came here today to see it for themselves
the fact is this was a serious sober and
civil day whatever you think of the
evidence it's now available for all to
see cordelia left Sky News Washington